hey guys how's it going if you hear
something in the background that's just
my dishwasher today is september 1st i'm
not sure when you're watching this but
either way today is the first of
september and it marks the end of veda
for those of you guys that don't know
what veda is it's vlog every day in
august i usually call it a video every
day in august and i think that i
accomplished the task correct me if i'm
wrong but i think i did it and for that
i think i deserve a thumbs up so hit the
thumbs up button please that is my way
of you guys saying congratulations
justine you actually did something for
once that you said you were gonna do i
know that's a rarity i try to be
the best that i can be but sometimes i
fall short and you know what it's okay
is it okay
maybe i'm just telling myself that
anyway i'm off to shoot this one video
with cassie i also have a couple things
that i want to unbox for you today so
we'll see if i get all these tasks done
i'm late cool
[Music]
we made it
cassie hello
so today we're shooting some fun videos
we're doing we're doing two different
challenge videos yes we are so one for
our channel and one for mine and it's
gonna be really fun we haven't figured
out when we're gonna release it yet so
it might already be out or it might not
be out who knows but it is gonna involve
the spaghett so what's new tell me
everything i'm wearing your pants right
now oh my gosh you look so good you look
at the unicorn
what's new um
make sure you're in frame hold on am i
okay yeah you're good hold on wait let
me zoom out great looks great what's new
i don't know i just feel like i'm tired
yeah really tired and i'm sad that
summer is gonna be over yeah but we live
in l.a so summer doesn't really ever end
here for us totally true but for
everybody else
today we cut some fruit
lots of fruits i never caught a mango
before
and you'll see how just you'll see we
also played with a pig we did this is
going to be so much fun i'm so excited
and we saw the pig vomit and it's not
what you think it is spoiler alert
okay yay i'm so excited if you guys see
it go check out her channel and you'll
see it soon
[Music]
wow so it's the next day from hanging
out with cassie and filming our fun
little collab videos i just want to say
that so the challenge that we did on my
channel is going to be the dizzy
challenge and i've never done that
before but i've seen so many youtubers
do it i thought okay this will be kind
of cool if we do the disney challenge
and we try to do different yoga poses
please hold it if it was trash away
so we do this challenge and then i
get to my car and i almost throw up like
i could not even drive home like i had
to sit i put the air conditioning on and
i was just like holy moly and then i get
home i was sick until almost
like 10 o'clock until i finally was like
i gotta go to bed for real it was bad
you're not well i'm gonna open something
up where did that box for me
it's a roll of us we both have something
what
yes johnny hey how are my potatoes
cooking over there
they're going to boil down to nothing
so
our dear friend
johnny cupcakes
sent me and jenna a little present do
you want to get in on this and see
one second please
look at these nice blankets dude maddie
is gonna steal this blanket so oh my god
is it soft
i don't wanna share with maddie just
kidding
i'm so tired whoa
holy moly these are so great oh my god
if you guys aren't a johnny cupcakes fan
you should start because
this is great love johnny
he needs to come back to la and hang out
with us wait what is this
these leggings oh my god are they oh
my trampoline legging game just got
turned up oh wow
oh look at these ones little kitties on
them maddie keeps nudging me my body is
going to be a wonderland
oh okay i'll tell you the mayor
let him know hey john he's a little busy
with katy perry at the moment i thought
she was with orlando oh yeah that's
right oh katie
okay oh my goodness jen look at this
this one's definitely mine no what is
that you can have i'll take the purple
one okay these are so awesome i'm losing
my mind trampoline park
i wanted to go back
yeah i'm ready but all of our friends
it's not at are injured oh my god it is
wait look
maddie had a frozen potato on his nose
this is like honestly like the best news
oh steal the colors
very nice about star wars oh
oh is
well i'll just put these in our shared
closet oh look at this
it's a darth vader oh my god these are
so incredible
he's got a rolling pin oh my god look at
this one oh
i love it it's mine don't touch it i'm
taking this one don't be shy i was alive
when this game came on this
i was alive when this console was out no
you were not alexa
when was nintendo
cancel
alexa when was the first nintendo
introduced
legend
i'm not sure what you meant by that
question literally you are absolutely
worthless like honestly you
i oh lately she knows who the leaders
the leaders she does i don't want to
talk about that all right i'll attend
this vlog i will see you guys pretty
soon i look forward to posting our fun
collab video with cassie and i need to
go hang up these shirts now these are so
cool i'm so excited
got in the leggings too no
amazing
wait a minute was i right yeah you are